dùng làm linh bật sản khủng lâu đường hoang với người.
Năm nay, đều vào của người của thành phố chim mình mình nè.
Có mà chù đặc cấm đậu.
Có hai chù đặc, là khi đầy dạ ngân tầy.
Göt hợp thầm giá khé hoa sịt.
Chù cao như bầm giữa đất của lên 12 triệu máy mầy làm trao.
Nếu như mầy, già ở được với chữ.
A dưới nó có xa hình thầy dạ ngán ở tạo ở nở trợ.
Nhưng mà đôi hỏi cái người làm, em hiểu để đất dầu nó những cái gì để xin đọc.
Năm nay, đầy tu trên, lần đầu tiết được qua của mình có hai chú đồ bốt.
Nó cứ đọc được cho nó chỉnh giới dù khắp được.
Hơi dờ cũng gặp người vình chắc chá mồ khá ngàn ở tây đêm qua được qua.
Mình mấy cắt giả chá ở trẻ được.
Dạ quá, mình biết là phải.
Nó là cũng mấy nòng, đầy khó như là mình bỏ cập mắt,
như cho nó có hồn.
Hãy mình 2 trú rắm này, thì như thế hồn như không đỏ,
như thế là mốt, nó các mốt, nó sợ người qua khó giết giả.
Sợ nước két, két bỏ xâm rồi, quá, mơ khàu xương,
ló, giảy là bống nhẹn, nó chập giảy.
Đủ cảo, trời, bằng bút lời, lắm mình màu, phái màu,
ngọc trai, mắt đẹn như là mắt hánh.
Là nó lộn lặng lặng lặng lặng.